hey babies it's episode 171 of
congratulations you guys know that I'm
from New Jersey I got a New Jersey cub I
got that Starbuck cups I used to get him
for my hand all the time and then they
discontinued them and they started to
change it then it changed the artwork on
him and I was like [ __ ] you guys dude
that's how it goes that's just a mini
story for that ass
I don't like here's the deal I like the
de jure I like the cups
they're called the like at home or you
are here or this city rocks or some
[ __ ] what do they call it and I'm a
sucker dude if I buy one I buy all of
them it's my OCD babies and um well one
time I was a kid and I started
collecting a bunch of [ __ ] and I knew I
was gonna be a hoarder if I didn't stop
my desk look like a [ __ ] like a
mountain and and one day I was like dude
if I don't get rid of all this [ __ ]
right now then there's nothing I could
do I'm gonna [ __ ] keep him I'm gonna
be a hoarder you ever see that [ __ ] you
ever see hoarders where the guy was like
one guy collected his own [ __ ] he didn't
want to get rid of his own feces and so
he kept it in his outhouse in the back
that's an early but yeah dude kept his
feces hegai it's coming out here for a
racing but anyway so I got this these
all these states and cities and [ __ ] I
don't I also don't like how they have
states and cities I think that they
should like do one of the cities and one
of the states dude this way I could get
my aunt either the city's or the states
cuz I would get my aunt when no time I
was on the road the whole thing was I
had to be at the place to get the thing
I couldn't just order them and give to
my aunt I would be like hey aunt
Michelle guess what I was in [ __ ] you
know San Francisco so I get the one with
the San Francisco in the Golden Gate
Bridge and then she could drink her hot
coffee and she dude she would have her
ladies over like her friends and [ __ ]
and they would eat they would drink the
[ __ ] as well and just drink from
different cities dude it was real cute
I'm cute
dude I'm cute I'm cute with my family if
you know me and you say I'm not cute
with my family they do nice to meet you
you're a liar
and nice to meet you dude you're a liar
one time I was on stage before I worked
out and I was going like this and and I
was doing like this and afterwards my
ex-girlfriend she was like you should
start working now because you [ __ ]
tricep is flabby when you do that never
forgot it
Oh anyway dude I'm really [ __ ] dude
that's the thing I don't not tell you
guys that because of a [ __ ]
insecurity I have I got to lay all the
[ __ ] cards out on the table my bet my
babies ha ha ha
so anyway dude [ __ ] is real coronavirus
[ __ ] is getting real coronavirus that's
that [ __ ] what's-her-name betta be
what's her [ __ ] name cardi B cardi B
dude you know anything cardi B ever did
how about that how about any video cardi
B ever made uh that [ __ ] thing is
funny as [ __ ] though i screen recorded
it I don't know it was from some
Instagram that me they made it and it
makes me laugh and I keep getting it in
my head dude let me try to pull it up
here let me try to pull it up here you
guys up pull it up as I pull it up and
of course I can't find it but it's all
good dude that's how it is man you go to
look for some and you can't find it
great good great
Oh screen recordings is a thing here it
is
[Music]
Wow
the ends of us part the she got me
panicky and panicking panicking
dude [ __ ] that's a song that the
sound of that song not the words
obviously but the son of that song would
be a song that you'd listen to in a car
while you're sixteen with a girl and
you'd hook up with her but you wouldn't
have sex and she'd jerk you off and then
date your best friend and then that song
would always remind you of her deeper
issues anyway dude why would anybody
listen to this [ __ ] almost at a phone
call but I meant it is a phone call dude
anyway let me let me put out the people
who made this on T dot oh no wait it's
uh
youtube.com slash diss Disney Russian
Disney Russian music dude taking the
happiest music and making it the most
[ __ ] non happiest music it's a small
world after all it's a small world after
all
it's a small world after all it's a
small [ __ ] world okay
anyway eat borscht coronavirus [ __ ] is
getting real [ __ ] is getting real
coronavirus and then she jerk you off
and then go [ __ ] date your friend
coronavirus [ __ ] is getting real who's
coronavirus dude cardi B what is she
wearing what is she saying what kind of
makeup is she using why she was sticking
her tongue out
how are you famous her music bangs are
her music bangs oh I ain't scared i I'm
panicking I what did she say I'm
panicking a [ __ ] panicking I bet you
scared I don't know anyway dude that
[ __ ] rocks but I like I I don't like
that I don't like that um how about the
kid who made the [ __ ] butthole song
though that's what I want to play right
now the kid that I wonder what's inside
your butthole original song it says -
original song yeah we know dude a little
kid get it dude this kid [ __ ] rips
for real this is I don't know
this girl's name is opor formed by jolie
done i don't know if you've heard this
before it went kind of viral but this
girl's got a guitar it's as big as she
is she's got the [ __ ] haircut of the
girl from write said or no from ya know
Right Said Fred was at that movie I know
Right Said Fred was the drop dead Fred
was that the [ __ ] movie drop dead
Fred she's got the haircut of that girl
named Penelope anyway dude the guitars
as big as she is what is she like four
maybe and she Goods gonna maybe there
are astronauts and maybe there's aliens
all inside your butthole and dude I've
never looked inside a butthole I mean I
know what science says and doctors say
but I I've never looked inside a pothole
and if you're gonna be a conspiracy
theorist about some things that why
wouldn't you be conspiracist about all
of the things you believe in pizza Kate
Kate pizza cake that's a girl I dated
that likes pizza you believe in pizza
gate then why not believe in [ __ ]
aliens inside your butthole that guy
with the big-ass hair that goes like
this
aliens have been known to be inside of
blood holes that guy treats me he's a
fan anyway ancient aliens that's it
that's the [ __ ] like how she always
wants to know like it's not just like a
little bit it's not like once she's not
that she's like what's this at a
butt-hole to a doctor and doctors like
most of just [ __ ] or nothing and that
you guys okay cool but she's like wants
to do know about everybody
what's this such a butthole I always
want to know you ma'am what's inside you
butthole sorry why do you need to know I
always want to know have you learned
this right right but I always want to
know with everybody when I was a kid
dude I was at my grandma Carmela's house
s dalian and and she had a my grandpa
was grandpa Greg but he had already
passed I think as a sad and so grandma
Carmela do it you should look a little
bit like Joe Pesci no lie and so
Jeremiah if you're Italian if your
grandma if you're Italian and you
doesn't pass you a little bit guess what
you're not Italian and I didn't make the
rules but that's how it goes and so one
time she got a haircut when she was 75
or 80 years old and she what came home
and she said I think I look younger and
we were like how much [ __ ] younger
you're 90 um so dude we were we were at
the she was a [ __ ] pisser dude she
was a straight-up pisser she would eat
cherry pie for breakfast and my dad as a
joke would always whenever she would
wake up in the morning he'd have as a
joke her bags near the doorway and be
like okay well because she would come
and stay with us for like a month or two
during the summer it was cool and and my
dad realized put her bags in the front
door be like okay so you didn't like
pretend like she needs to leave and she
would laugh and then eat cherry pie for
breakfast but [ __ ] it dude when you're
80 do what you want anyway anyway she
she added we had a gathering at her
house it was like my hand my uncle my
uncle my hand my hand my aunt my uncle
Vinny my dad my mom all this [ __ ] oh
wait no my uncle Vinny the other side of
the family my aunt Michelle the one that
has the Starbucks cups anyway and I had
like oh it was Christmastime
and they had got me this this stand this
microphone stand that was like big and
blue and [ __ ] I don't know why they make
[ __ ] for kids like so not how it looks
in real life like just if when I was a
kid even I would be like they'd be like
yeah we got you a [ __ ] a microphone
in a mic stand it would be this [ __ ]
big blue dildo looking thing and you'd
just be like oh cool I guess I'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I know how these things
really look give me a real [ __ ] mic
stand dude and I and I and I I went off
to the other living room and to the
living room and they were in the dining
room and I started singing this song
that was on like Winnie the Pooh or some
[ __ ] I was like I'm a lucky dog I'm like
a dog I'm a lucky dog I'm like a dog and
I didn't know they were listening and at
the end they [ __ ] clapped so hard and
I was so [ __ ] embarrassed so Oh moral
stories watch that ass no matter where
you are your grandma's house and dude
it's so funny how kids want the real
[ __ ] like when you're a kid this how you
know like
want the real [ __ ] when you're a kid and
you dress up like I was robbing for
holiday I couldn't be Batman like what a
piece of [ __ ] I had to be Robin I'd be
different so I want to be robbing a my
mom made my Robin costume and I'll put
that [ __ ] on dude I wasn't getting candy
I was fighting crime you know what I
mean like I was like do you think that
maybe like I wouldn't my I might be
mistaken for Robin like I was not Batman
I am I am small you know what I mean so
maybe I'll maybe I'm Robin if somebody
needs assistance I could be here
I will help just [ __ ] running stop
evildoer so I got to go home I went
cocky I got to go home I went cocky and
I'm scared and so uh yeah but when you
put on that [ __ ] like I was a
werewolf
I was these were my Halloween costumes I
was the Punisher brought my mom put
cotton in my [ __ ] shirt with the
skull on it that she made and I looked
at buffer and I looked [ __ ] Hale dude
there's like pictures of me with dirt on
my face
I looked ill so you know I mean it was
makeup it wasn't dirt mom put makeup on
my deal you know I wasn't that rugged
but I looked at it I was probably like
[ __ ] eight years old and nine years
old and I look [ __ ] I look pretty ill
and so my cousin when he kids are
[ __ ] hilarious I can't wait to see
like what my kid will like want and do
like my cousin wanted [ __ ] in the
doctors gloves the rubber doctor's
gloves for Christmas that was only
thinking wanted for Christmas and he
would be like they'd be like so what do
you want Nick and he'd be like I want
doctor gloves and Miami she'll be like
what the [ __ ] he talking about what toys
they be like no be a doctor I want
doctor gloves and like he would just get
she's like all right [ __ ] we were
laughing man she'd be like this is what
he wants [ __ ] doctor glows so she got
him oh you know there's like $6.99 for a
pack now they're like $300 because of
that [ __ ] coronavirus [ __ ] is getting
real coronavirus Ally a [ __ ] is panicky
a [ __ ] is panicky
so anyway he would have those gloves and
just walk around the house as a [ __ ]
four-year-old like thinking he was a
real ass doctor you'd be like oh I put
my [ __ ] be like let me take a look at it
here let me take a look at it take two
of these and call me in the morning any
way you'd hand your cookies hey I'll
take two of these and call me in the
morning and your cookies Hey so clear up
in the morning anyway
[ __ ] I wonder what's inside that
butthole so but try to make my kid
laughs he won't laugh
he smiles big though he's a day away
from laughing I keep thinking of that
Ray Romano joke where he's just like
yeah I got a material my material
I don't know I'm butchering it but he's
like my material was getting better
because I'm like oh no I think he says
it's getting worse there's the only
thing I wrote in the past four days and
he just shakes his keys at the audience
I thought that [ __ ] was so funny and but
that's how I keep thinking of that cuz I
keep going like I keep saying like hey
boy you ain't got no teeth and I'll just
be like be like oh you ain't got no
teeth boy hey wear your teeth that your
teeth in your pocket and he just goes I
did a [ __ ] redneck I did a redneck
character to him and he seems to like
that I was doing like an old black lady
and then I thought it's kind of racist
even though he did but I want him to
grow up to be racist so I was like all
right let me do [ __ ] well that's more
races because that's who's racist
anyway I'm ruining my son's life so
every dad ruins their son's life or
daughter's life you just have to [ __ ]
minimize the ruining the lightness you
know it's [ __ ] crazy since I should
should I wish to park out a kid but yeah
so babies make [ __ ] real though like
it's so cool that it's so cool that like
you can like not be not sure about life
and then you have a kid and you're like
oh you like the wee baby oh okay I get
it
anyway if you've been watching my
Netflix special that's great some people
say they're watching it three or four
times love that
you guys are awesome love you for
watching it check out my Netflix special
if you haven't yet it's on Netflix and
it is streaming right now it's called no
pain and then watch the other ones to
man on fire and incorrigible and I have
an episode of comedians of the world
that is episode 2 I believe on the
Americans of the comedian the world yup
doing the American section you'll watch
all that stuff but yeah I'm just about
done with this [ __ ] quarantine you
know what I mean not for real I
understand I'm gonna do what everybody's
doing how about that I'm gonna do what
everybody's doing that's the thing
quarantine is the most if you can't beat
them join them scenario I have ever
[ __ ] heard all right it's like
alright everyone's staying indoors then
guess what your boys staying indoors but
you're starting to protest you start to
go out what are the rules for that I
[ __ ] it fine [ __ ] it if we're all
getting we're getting it
you're all getting it you're all [ __ ]
shaking hands and holding the hands and
protests [ __ ] are out there
holding hands and protests why do you
have to hoe I'd have to rub it and
everyone's [ __ ] faces just protests
just be like open it up open it up open
up the country open it up but duty I'm
I'm if you get if you can't beat them
join them fine if everyone's gonna be
driving around getting the [ __ ] than
alright let's go get this [ __ ]
[ __ ] let's go get this [ __ ] dude
let's get it dude come on doorways and
[ __ ] let's get it no III [ __ ]
panicking but you know what are we gonna
what am I gonna be why my people won't
[ __ ] one of the only guys sitting in
his house chillin trying to not get that
[ __ ] Roni virus everyone out there
going to [ __ ] Incubus concerts and
[ __ ] and I'm over here just not touring
not making those [ __ ] bags sure I
make the [ __ ] podcast sponsor bag but
I'll make the [ __ ] Road bags that's
my bread and butter baby I swear to god
dude after this quarantine is over one
thing the quarantine is [ __ ] made me
learn and I'm telling you and I know
this isn't relatable and you know what
dude I don't give a [ __ ] I'll tell you
this much do it I'm spending money like
a [ __ ] do this the second this
quarantine ends I go out and I spend
[ __ ] money I bring stacks of cash
like I'm [ __ ] c-murder
or [ __ ] Master P and I just
show up at places buying [ __ ] every
dude straight up [ __ ] like this how
much I do it dude and then I go to
another store no dude I'm spending money
I'm gay
cuz here's the thing man I would be like
nad I don't know if I want to spend I
don't know if I'm gonna get the guy I
got the chain [ __ ] you know it costs
some money I bought that [ __ ] a little
bit a while ago I should probably not
buy the watch dude when quarantine is
over and your boys on the road he's
getting that watch bro you think I won't
be different you think I won't be
different when the quarantine ends holy
[ __ ] bro I'll be so different
you'd think I'm Asian I don't give up I
sort of God I'll be shorter I'll be a
different person I'll be wear a bandanas
and I just where's this what am i doing
how we livin I'm cooped up in my house I
didn't get my kitchen done Oh what bro
when this quarantine
when trunk goes quarantine is over I go
bring the [ __ ] dudes over we're doing
the kitchen I'm going on tour doing the
I'm redoing rooms that I don't even need
to redo I'm getting chimneys all sorts
of chimneys on the top of my house I
don't even have fireplaces I'll get them
people ate but you don't have a front
please I'll be like I'll get them later
we could put a chimney up why do I have
the money for what all I'm doing is
postmates sin and watching Netflix I
can't wait to spend those [ __ ] monies
jackets dude it'll be [ __ ] summertime
till next year jackets up on jackets
iced out gold teeth pulling up in
something so far in it's unreal
something so far you gonna be like
where's that from I'll be like oh it's
from a country they just started there's
only five guys there what yeah I know
they just make cars this is one of them
Wow what color is that didn't come out
yet see you later
I'll do that [ __ ] skid that were you
bucked twice before you go you think I'd
do one [ __ ] no way I go
I go like that dude and I take off an
airplanes that take off like this [ __ ]
these I don't do these anymore
I don't need a runway dude I do like the
GI Joe [ __ ] where the [ __ ] things go
and then I go Shh or or or I cartoon it
I get an airplane that takes off like
this like that dude like a goddamn I
said I write to the next destination
like this like the roadrunner you think
I won't do it I'm saying it now so you
know when I show up with a bedazzled
green cape with a collar that goes
higher than my head and a and a [ __ ]
medallion over the thing that has a big
C on it you don't say well what happen
to Chris because you [ __ ] know
so let's go out let's get this
coronavirus all become [ __ ] immune
and then spend this money after we could
get jobs again cuz what are we doing
with all this what are we doing I you
know look if people live had a mouth I
get it but you know it's like that's
[ __ ] 150 degrees it's all good man but
I'm spending that money and mark my
[ __ ] words kind bars out the ass just
all of them all and it's not even
expensive but like people are like why
does he fill his car with so many
[ __ ] boxes of kind bars it's like
well because he just spends money that's
it and he doesn't want to talk about it
what's like you know in the car the car
is [ __ ] something far into it it's a
new country I will do that and I can't
wait I can't wait
[ __ ] pissed me off just are to
make a money and then the [ __ ] whole
world shuts down whatever dude listen to
NPR if you want to be relatable dude
this shit's about this cult I got to
start watching Waco rest are watching
Waco pick up some [ __ ] tidbits play
with that that guy Taylor Jenkins or
whatever the [ __ ] his name is Taylor
Kitsch Hagen's hitch Taylor Kitsch guys
good looking bro you think you're good
looking bro alright I see you do it I
saw you once Wow
not even in LA forget where I think I
was in Nashville I don't remember where
the [ __ ] I was but I was there do it and
I saw you with five dudes and you were
the best-looking one but dude that
doesn't fade me that doesn't faze me I
have a [ __ ] personality okay yeah I
look like a big bird but it's all good
man
so you're gonna walk in the room dude
Taylor Hinkins you're just gonna walk in
the [ __ ] room okay all right all
right
he cuts his hair
[ __ ] he cuts his hair and does a
mullet and looks better how he doesn't
feel did it and look like a lesbian he
does it and looks better somehow and
puts on some funky glasses and does Waco
and you look better dude
I'll fight you till my last breath and
it'll be way before your last breath by
the way my wind is not good but so
anyway let's do some [ __ ] ads man see
these nighttime episodes are firing on
all cylinders not syllables wow I said
it right I keep saying firing on all
cylinders all cylinders and I know that
and I kept saying it I was having a
brain fart
anyway um where do I get these [ __ ]
ads see that's the thing I open up too
many tabs and then it [ __ ] I was
looking at Easy's dude I'm [ __ ] 40
saw some guy was like Dress your age bro
when the [ __ ] are you supposed to what
19 year olds are making money alright I
could just started making money I'll be
buying the [ __ ] that's fresh cuz I want
to look fresh and brought you let's not
forget I'm the youngest man alive bro
[ __ ] y'all um Taylor eight Kenyans
alright dude here we go babies post
mates when you need red wine at 4 p.m.
sushi at 9 p.m. a breakfast burrito at 8
a.m. and apropos Fionn at 10 a.m.
post made it post mates is your personal
food delivery grocery store delivery
whatever kind of delivery service all
year round anything you're craving
postman's can deliver
they're the largest on-demand network in
the US and offer delivery from all the
restaurants grocery and convenience
stores and traditional retailers you
could possibly want or need 24 hours a
day if the restaurant or convenience
stores open they're open 365 days a year
postman's will bring you what you need
within the hour dude I got sushi almost
every night last week and posts mated it
you can even do it with sushi download
the app for iOS or Android for free
browse local restaurants and businesses
and track your delivery and real time no
more trip to the store you don't even
need to know where the store is to be
brutally honest with you
pasta mates will deliver anything to you
for a limited time post mates is giving
our listeners $100 of free delivery
credit for your first seven days that's
awesome to start your free deliveries
download the app and use congrats that's
the code Congrats
that's code congrats for $100 of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days
when you download the post mates app
anything you need anytime you need it
post mate it download post mates and
save with the code Congrats better help
so better is there something interfering
with your happiness or is it preventing
you from achieving your goals
nah no stranger to that you know I mean
we all have our things and some are good
and some are bad but stress gets in the
way for me better help assesses your
needs and matches you with your own
licensed professional therapist you can
start communicating in under 24 hours
that's very quick it's not a crisis line
it's not self-help it's professional
counseling done securely online there's
a broad range of expertise and better
helps counselor network which may not be
locally available in many areas the
services available for clients worldwide
you'll get timely thoughtful responses
plus you can schedule weekly video our
phones exigence so you won't ever have
to sit in an uncomfortable waiting room
it's awesome it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is even available so check
that out huh visit better help calm /
Congrats and join the over 500,000
that's half a million people taking
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional
congratulations listeners get 10% off
your first month at better help calm
Congrats
better help calm / Congrats that's what
that is so go to better help calm
Congrats yay coronavirus [ __ ] is getting
real coronavirus Bryce thinking about
the other day I drove by these
basketball courts that I played last
time I played basketball I drove by
these I went and I played with my friend
Rick Glassman and I went to this school
and I hopped the fence like a [ __ ] I
was 36
or 33 I don't even know I too old and I
was like yeah I'll do it I'll get some
exercise I put on a [ __ ] tank top and
a bandana and I want to go play
basketball and I hadn't played
basketball in Jesus nine years and I was
so uncool I was like oh okay this is the
last time I'm never playing basketball
you ever have that decision in life
where you're just like oh oh alright
this will be this will be it this will
be it for me I'm done and I'm telling
you right now I will never play
basketball again do you understand why
I'm over 18 and I don't play in the NBA
or college so my basketball it was never
even really a [ __ ] fun dude I
remember somebody won one time it's guy
named Greg can't members last name in
high school he was like what are gonna
be when I grow up and I said I'll be in
the NBA and he goes like this well at
least you got the drive and I don't know
why I said that cuz I didn't want to be
in the NBA I thought it did why would I
want that dude I'm a [ __ ] comedian
obviously dude I would do the dumbest
[ __ ] in school I'm gonna be in the NBA
man oh really
get your 6-2 and white yeah yeah yeah
I'm gonna be a I'm gonna be a um the guy
under the bass it's just like if you
want the ball that badly you just have
it you know I'm [ __ ] 40 you want
people on to play at the YMCA and
they're like do the ball and I'm just
like here you go man I'm gonna check
[ __ ] online I think it's so weird
when people want to you know be like 38
year old
like past the rock all right okay the
rock um but yeah after quarantine I'm
putting a basketball [ __ ] rink in my
house
basketball drink I don't remember what
the [ __ ] I was gonna say but oh I got
instead of watching Sopranos man you
know I watch Breaking Bad if you're a
loyal congratulations podcast listener
you know you know [ __ ] daddy watch
Breaking Bad you know how you watched it
you know how you watched it and you
[ __ ] props to Aaron Paul and Brian
Cranston and obviously it's so good it's
one it's maybe the best show I've ever I
think it's the best show I've ever seen
it is the best show I've ever seen it's
so thrilling and then he turned on
Sopranos and it's so good in a different
way you know I was talking my brother my
brothers like well yeah bacon Breaking
Bad's like a thriller but man that
[ __ ] Sopranos man you you watch that
[ __ ] you're just like yeah yeah yeah I'm
Italian even if you're not a time you're
like yeah yeah yeah yeah I got it
hey yo make me [ __ ] dinner to your
girl she's like I'm excuse me
your psyche try to watch [ __ ] TV yeah
Mar on my mom says Martin like for real
and my great grandma and my great
grandma to my grandma would say Martin
and she would say I'm making a sauce for
the meatballs my grandma Carmela little
uh Joe Pesci and um and my great-grandma
I don't even know what the [ __ ] which is
called a great-grandma I don't know if
she had a name but she was oldest [ __ ]
she was like nineteen nine and she died
cuz she fell down some stairs yep she
fell down some stairs broke her hip went
to the hospital and that was it she was
like peace out like that mean were the
guys [ __ ] going peace out and he just
gets more and more dissolved and she
broke her hip and she got to the
hospital and she was like nah not doing
this [ __ ] no no no you what you want to
do so my hip back together I [ __ ] y'all
see ya Martin and then and we would we
me and my brother do
we would [ __ ] we thought it was a
funniest [ __ ] thing to make her do
super grandma like we'd be like dead Dan
ass super grandma I'll be like grandma
will you go like this like she was
flying and she would have the [ __ ]
she always I never saw the bottom half
of her of her of her body she always had
a blanket over her legs I never saw her
walk anywhere
she just had a blanket over like a
nicest [ __ ] blanket over her legs always
no matter how it could be 95 degrees and
every time she thought she'd be like
gone DiBella to this day I know what it
means I think it means beautiful Grand
Ave and she'd kiss me one day and nobody
she could add robot like stall I know
and we'd be like grandma can you do
super super grandma after we say super
after we say super grandma will you put
your hands up and we'd be like then that
is super grandma and she go like this
and we would [ __ ] be rolling on the
ground man we'd be 6 and 2 we'd be 8 and
4 dude roll in on the [ __ ] ground
super grandma man and then she fell
downstairs a burglar Hampson died but
it's all good but you know we all have
to go and she was 90 something man she
lived her life and then when my grandma
died my grandma Carmela I was afraid of
flying I was like 22 and my mom is like
you've got to come and I was like I
can't - scared and last minute I decided
to go and I wrote this [ __ ] eulogy
and I went on stage whatever the [ __ ] in
front everyone and I gave it
ice and ice and I gave a little thing
about my grandma and I started crying
when I was talking about her on um you
know we were Catholic or whatever [ __ ]
man my brother and I [ __ ] the priest
dude
funerals and anything baptisms and all
this [ __ ] if you're Catholic they're so
[ __ ] ridiculous like take those
[ __ ] garbs off you know the Hat goes
so high it's like got a loaf of bread in
it what do you have in there pogs you
know what I mean
and he's just like Donovan you're on the
board or they won't know Lordy forever
and ever
all right dude and the [ __ ] priest
was so [ __ ] dude he would do [ __ ] like
so now we're going to what oh okay okay
and and we and either my brother or I
said it - he said it to me or I said it
Tammany like I was so [ __ ] insecure
that's it
that
dude we [ __ ] were crying so hard
laughing not because we were sad because
we were laughing and my dad's like the
[ __ ] you doing and I was like he [ __ ]
hilarious and we were laughing dude even
super Gramm I couldn't [ __ ] save the
day dude we were done we were done
funerals are the funniest [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude everyone's just standing around and
like they're [ __ ] men in black and
the people that were really close to the
person who's sitting in front like
there's a [ __ ] agenda and the person
just in the box like this just [ __ ]
put him in the ground dude bro when I
die just [ __ ] throw me that's it
throw me just get my friend a credit
hello yeah Chris died oh [ __ ] all right
yeah gets five buddies if they're not
buddies just grab some people around
he's here just [ __ ] throw me out of
the house I don't as far as I go
that's where I'm ending up don't bury me
don't nothing I want people stepping oh
joy I want people still seeing my wife
you know what I mean like oh well he's
in the way it just drive over and we
don't give a [ __ ] that's where he wanted
to be may he rest in peace [ __ ] all this
berry and [ __ ] people want to be burned
and kept on an on a [ __ ] mantle dude
[ __ ] my carcass dude I mean no not
really like you know what I mean like
that's a throwback to the last episode
but like dude throw me as far as I go
that's where I'm gonna be
I want [ __ ] you know how people are
like you know how people are like hey
when I die I don't want your lap I don't
want you Brian
I want you I want a celebration I want
it to be happy I want to celebrate I
want you to celebrate my life [ __ ] that
cry hard cry long dude I wanted you so
upset that it's affecting your diet I
want people getting skinnier people that
I never even met like I'm Michael
Jackson just like when he did when he
was 19 he played Gavin just [ __ ] I
want that
romi far as far as you can won't be that
far I mean how [ __ ] far can you throw
a guy yeah he's on his street
what yeh just [ __ ] he made it almost
to the street he's half on the street
and half his legs partner over on the
sidewalk and it they have to get the
gate open because it can't close because
it's it just hits his legs and then goes
back
she's just Christ why didn't you bury
him he didn't want to be buried he said
in his will he said you can have all the
money as long as you just have me thrown
I don't like ceremonies dude whenever
you gotta get dressed up and [ __ ] better
also when you're when you throw me only
have me I want [ __ ] underwear on and
that's it no no I want a shirt too so
then when I [ __ ] when I'm throwing
the shirt like is up a little bit you
know and I'm just like I'm my [ __ ]
front sidewalk just like my nipple
showing a little bit with my arm behind
my back like like a Family Guy fall you
know how his [ __ ] arm alone about for
real dude Jesus Christ Chris is all
[ __ ] yeah he's dead just come on and
we have food anyway dude yeah but the
whole thing about ceremonies is just
[ __ ] man baptisms and [ __ ]
confirmations and graduations give me
the diploma don't give me the diploma
[ __ ] I did it I'm done
I got to show up again with a [ __ ]
flat hat go [ __ ] yourself well would I
put the tassel what is this [ __ ]
grease dude let me just do what I want I
want to wear a t-shirt and that's it Wow
hope my son gets it man I hope my son
just shows up to graduation in only a
shirt that
Raven Damone a tan tan tan tan tan that
philip defranco dant there mr. Dahlia
you know I couldn't say his name so you
don't [ __ ] stalk him [ __ ]
there and then he comes up just only a
shirt [ __ ] tassel rips it off each
other on their Dam just flipping you the
[ __ ] off I'm gonna be a [ __ ]
scientist there's no goal to be a
scientist just doesn't give a [ __ ] Cinco
de drinko if you say Cinco to drink oh
you [ __ ] suck dude [ __ ] is getting
real coronavirus [ __ ] is getting real
throw me when I'm dead
um dude that that's a dope tube that
would be and that'll give a [ __ ] for me
Windham did that would be a good Tupac
song I don't give a [ __ ] throw me when
I'm dead you'd be like what he wants me
thrown Wow dude I'm [ __ ] hungry yeah
but it's all good dude we eat when we
eat I'm doing the podcast cuz I love it
and we're off the rails and that's fine
cuz I worked out hard I worked out
[ __ ] hard dude you want to know what
I did okay I'll tell you I did [ __ ]
incline chests with [ __ ] 60 pounds
that's what I got in the garage and I
[ __ ] did it
I go I go [ __ ] blast up and then
down like a Viper three seconds hold it
one second and then sew it one more time
and then again and I do that [ __ ] 12
rounds or uh sorry set or uh reps and I
did that five sets and then I do the one
where you hold it like this you know
like you're cold and I do two 45s and I
go like this up like that so it's
[ __ ] getting the shoulders too so you
know cuz your boys got [ __ ] wide
shoulders man and then I do I superset
that with [ __ ] incline flyes oh great
workout because oh oh I'm not done dude
oh no that sounds like a really cool
hard work oh yeah oh yeah well I'm not
done we just getting started so then I
did [ __ ] I forget oh those [ __ ]
kettlebell squat swear I [ __ ] push it
up like that I think I did 25 or 35 up
like that and I do eight of those and I
do it round I do that and then I do box
jumps and put into push-ups and then
[ __ ] that TRX ban where I put my feet
in it I do push-ups and bring my feet in
you get the [ __ ] core work and then I
do then I did regular push-ups and then
I did Oh were you lay on him know what
you're [ __ ] call him out know what
these exercises call Bob went on the
back and I would I would I would [ __ ]
bring the on my back I would on the
bench I was laying on my bench and I was
bringing my my [ __ ] wait for these 45
pounds up like this whatever dude that's
the most boring I've ever been on this
pot guys and I don't give a [ __ ] do it
because I like to tell her I'm up and
then what do I do
I did another thing - oh yeah jumping
around or some [ __ ]
alright guys nutria full you know look
women don't often talk about thinning
hair but nearly half of all women
experience it by as early as age 42
believe that and that's so even though
that's I mean that's so young I'm 40 and
I'm so young so if you're one of them
you know it can feel scary and stressful
which only adds to the problem it means
bad for a guy to lose his hair but you
know if you're a woman you know nutria
fall is formulated with potent
botanicals to help you grow hair as
strong as you are
and it's physician formulated to be 100%
drug free and that crazy that's amazing
neutral fall is physician 4-minute to be
100% drug free they use natural
clinically effective botanicals for
better hair growth through whole body
health on top of thicker stronger hair
without lasers or chemicals neutrophils
ingredients may also help you get a
handle on better sleep stress skin nails
and libido and a man that's sounds that
sounds great
when you subscribe a visit neutral
neutral fold calm and take their hair
wellness quiz for custom eye product
recommendations and when you subscribe
you'll receive monthly deliveries so you
never miss a dose shipping is free and
you can polish or cancel anytime so
that's great does it work yeah 77% of
women saw improvements in just 90 days
so you do the math ok you can grow
thicker healthier hair and support our
show by going to neutral fold calm and
using promo code congrats to get 20% off
this is their best offer available
anywhere alright something we bought at
Google in it plus free shipping on every
order get 20% off at neutral fold calm
promo code Congrats their best offer
anywhere 20% off at neutral fold calm
spelled nu t ra f o el calm promo code
congrats for hair as strong as you are
yes so but I got to start watching this
[ __ ] some more Sopranos I'm on season
3 did jacket that [ __ ] richie up real
when he gives him the jacket the jacket
yeah I give I got that hood
if that guy's so like would have been al
pacino's career if it wasn't for our
Pacino cut who that guy is
it's that guy's [ __ ] name Ritchie up
real David praval on the HBO series this
guy's so good in it
David probe all that's the thing you
watch these [ __ ] shows like you and
you look at these interviews now of them
and they're like [ __ ] twenty from New
York and we were talking about the
public teacher I mean al [ __ ] Petrine
Petrino al Patrice O'Neal oh yeah oh
yeah dude
I need to start doing [ __ ] acting and
act like Al Pacino and just [ __ ] take
over for Al Pacino oh yeah
be like yeah oh yeah we want Cristal
leave for the part okay cool and then I
show up and I'm like so what are we
doing guy is there just like so you walk
in the scene here and you drop your keys
down and then you say you say where's my
girl cuz you're looking for your
girlfriend and action where's my girl
they're just like cut okay try again and
action where's my girl okay yeah Chris
um you're you sound like Al Pacino and
I'm being like oh yeah it's cuz he died
and I want to [ __ ] I mean you get him
what do you mean I'm acting like Al
Pacino because people like how much you
know what's the problem here and at that
big enough a star that the case I know
the jacket in Sopranos cool
it's funny when acting is like people
really take it so seriously like
Christian Bale just [ __ ] losing
weight and chopping it he's doing a new
role was chopping his head off did you
know that he's playing Sleepy Hollow and
he's legitimately shop
chopping his head off and then he's
doing another roll where he's just his
head so and then that'll be his last
roll they're gonna use the head he
chopped off for another he's shooting
two movies at once oh man when Christian
Bale [ __ ] flipped out oh how about
this dude when Christian Bale flipped
out oh wow we never talked about this
did we good for you when he does that
good photo yay so [ __ ] whatever he is
flip out on terminator let me tell you
something about this dude oh the
Christian Bale flip out I'm on Christian
Bale side everyone's like wow what an
[ __ ]
[ __ ] that dude the lighting guy was
[ __ ] with the light when he was
acting good this is what happened I
don't have heard it here we go
kick your [ __ ] ass I want you off the
[ __ ] set you prick now don't just be
sorry think for one [ __ ] second that
the [ __ ] are you doing dude it's so and
the guys being so nice about he's like
I'm sorry Christian
I'm sorry don't just be sorry think
about what you're doing so [ __ ]
Scottish but whatever and are you
professional or not yes Oh went for the
jugular yes I am the guy's so nice he's
so nice he sounds like a lady do I
[ __ ] walk around and rip that no shut
the [ __ ] up nice nice nice the guy
started to cut him off and he'd just use
that anger no shut the [ __ ] up do i
[ __ ] walk around but I know shut the
[ __ ] up you gotta let a guy go when the
guys off the ground like that you just
gotta wait for him to land you don't say
anything
you start eating crackers for real if
anyone ever gets mad that mad at me I
carry you know I carry around [ __ ]
gummy bears just for that just in case
anyone gets me mad okay gets that mad at
me I just I have a I take out a lawn
chair I go crap and I wipe it out and I
[ __ ] sit down and I opened my gummy
bears that I have been saving and I just
wait are you a professional and I'm
eating [ __ ] a red one because you
can't do you can't be like well no yeah
hold up a sec it doesn't work I'm eating
gummy bears do i what no no don't shut
me up I'm not gonna walk around and rip
your [ __ ] lights down Wow
I mean am I gonna walk around and rip
your [ __ ] lights down obviously not
you know but maybe it's making up grant
appointment in the middle of a scene
then why the [ __ ] are you walking right
through that at that I like this in the
background what the [ __ ] is it with you
what don't you [ __ ] understand he's
right
you got any [ __ ] idea about hey it's
[ __ ] distracting you got any [ __ ]
idea about hi it's [ __ ] distracting
or a sentence of all time but still with
him I'm in dude if I was there if I was
[ __ ] sam worthington or whatever
because this is on the Terminator movie
I would have been Sam I would have been
behind him like wow yeah dude he's right
you know
do you have any idea about how [ __ ]
distracting sam worthington if you tried
to draw Sam Worthington you wouldn't
know what to do
he's so famous but whoa is he you know
you'd be like what is this [ __ ] nose
do is just kind of regular right but
he's in the biggest movies of all time
they make a movie called Jesus Christ
and he'll play [ __ ] Jesus Christ do
it having somebody walking up behind
Bryce in the middle of the [ __ ] scene
give me a [ __ ] answer yes what don't
you get about it I was looking at the
light oh good for you and I was looking
at the light oh wow so patronizing
patron our patron I'd never know I was
looking at the light oh good for you
and how was it oh wow I can't wait to
see what would I say well I was looking
for the light how good for you how was
it I'd be like you know it was fine then
I I didn't I didn't mean to get in the
scene he's he eats gummi bears I hope it
was [ __ ] good because it's useless
now isn't it nice
[ __ ] sake man your amateur Wow
said he's an amateur this is the thing
though with actors it's like he's doing
a scene that's [ __ ] really intense
obviously robots are trying to destroy
the world and he's using that intent and
then a [ __ ] lighting guy does that
[ __ ] and then the dude Christian Bale is
just like using that intensity and
people are like what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude he's not he's just acting man I'm
gonna play a [ __ ] for real all all
dude I'll be playing my Japanese guy or
whatever or the [ __ ] in a movie or a
Christian or a Christian a [ __ ] uh
British dude and then somebody will move
a light and I'll just I would do oh you
really freaked aha you're getting a
movie [ __ ] law and it'll be like what
chris is a dick but why is he British
when he's dick like all he was playing
he was it was [ __ ] that movie with
Sherlock Holmes cool my computer's not
working that sounds great look G you got
[ __ ] something to say to this prayer
oh wow
well somebody should be fine Mick G dude
me too you got something to say to this
prick Jesus I didn't see it happen
oh dude now you know where McCheese
stands dude alright okay okay nobody
went to his [ __ ] bro
Christian Bale I would have been right
there dude the [ __ ] jerky comedian
just [ __ ] watch him and keeping an eye
on him there's a second time that he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about what is going
on in front of the cameras dick then
dude all right I'm trying to [ __ ] him do
a scene here and I'm going what the [ __ ]
is Shane walking in there I'm trying to
do a scene and I'm saying what a [ __ ] is
Shane walking in there what is he doing
there do you understand my mind is not
in the scene if you're doing that yeah
stay off the [ __ ] set man Wow [ __ ]
sake this is so funny to me stay off the
[ __ ] set man just so after the fit
just you know what man stay off the
[ __ ] set man just got real got down
to brass tacks you know no I don't care
let's go again
nice not take a [ __ ] minute
let's go again that's so funny when you
get that heated there's nothing you can
do like he's like oh let's go again and
the guy says well we can take a minute
and he says let's take a minute like you
can't suggest anything you he could the
people could have been like do you want
a [ __ ] we have that [ __ ] Emily
Ratajkowski okay okay oh [ __ ] guys I'll
be like okay well we got Tyson Beckford
then and he'll [ __ ] I just went back to
[ __ ] oh now [ __ ] goes again
like you can't win and let's not have
you [ __ ] walking in can I have Tom
put this on please you're unbelievable
man you un-fuckin'-believable and stop
it's the best number of times you're
strolling the [ __ ] around in the
background I've never had a DP behave
like this ah
you don't [ __ ] understand what it's
like working with actors that's what
that is
that's what that is man I'm telling you
is it dude where is this fun - and I'm
telling away dude and they wouldn't have
done that otherwise I can't [ __ ] stop
it dude i goddamn hate mac computers man
where the [ __ ] is it here enough got it
got it got it we said something and he's
just like what does he say [ __ ] I missed
it now I gotta go back goddammit uh you
don't [ __ ] understand what it's like
working with that that's what don't
[ __ ] understand what it's like
working with actors you don't understand
dude I know there's no video of it but I
wait I hope you won't like this like
this you don't understand you know how
is working with actors
ah you don't [ __ ] understand what
it's like working with actors that's
what that is that's what that is man I'm
telling you I'm not asking I'm telling
you you wouldn't have done that
otherwise I want to [ __ ] kick your
[ __ ] ass you know shut up for a sec
oh he went after him dude [ __ ] kick
your [ __ ] ass oh come on come on Wow
dude what if he just got leveled what if
the dude just went [ __ ] oh man
another thing you could do is this if a
guy starts talking like that if you're
on gummi bears you just go like this I
bet that would [ __ ] what yeah oh I
would do that I got to do that either
the gummi bears don't have gummy bears
do that anyway dude [ __ ] it's funny dude
I'm so hot right now I scream and I
sweat you don't understand
I don't work with [ __ ] it don't
[ __ ] understand it's working with
actors right no that's what it is good
for you
anyway uh what else see that [ __ ]
that they were doing air shows for the
workers dude it was so funny seeing the
air shows for the workers they were like
they were like yeah well we got the
[ __ ] fighting angels or whatever the
[ __ ] they call them you know six
airplanes just [ __ ] flying over to
give moral support for the people
risking their lives into the ER and
getting coronavirus and [ __ ] doctors
dying it did look I'm not a doctor I'll
never be a doctor but you know get a if
I want if I'm a doctor here's my thought
get a [ __ ] airplane just chill dude
this thing's gonna cost a million
dollars just relax
these air [ __ ] shows they're looking
for any excuse well the fighting angels
are coming out because Walmart you know
as there's a sale and so the fighting
are coming out and it's really cool and
then there was an interview with the guy
and they were like in one of the
fighting angels that's not what the
called I'm just making it up but they
were whatever they're called they were
like so is it right it was on I think it
was Fox News because Fox News is always
trying to like report on good [ __ ]
that's happening and even when there's
not good [ __ ] which there's [ __ ]
barely in a good ship because the
coronavirus [ __ ] is getting real that
[ __ ] they're just like well the
fighting angels flew around because
that's good and so they were like yeah
so is it true that you guys can get it
up to 18 feet close to each other when
you're in formation and the guy goes
like this
10 inches hey don't do that
dude you know how I think was actually
18 inches that's 18 inches hey these are
my hands not planes why does it matter
also your [ __ ] 17 miles away up in
the sky I can't tell if you're 10 feet
away or [ __ ] 18 inches away just be
10 feet away and the doctors dated
interview they're like so how do you
feel and they were like well I feel like
it's really cool you know it's really
cool that they did that for moral
support and makes us feel really good
like dude they were lying through their
[ __ ] teeth they don't give a [ __ ]
they'd even watch the [ __ ] thing they
were in the [ __ ] ER people are just
come on here we go and the [ __ ]
fighting angels are just I'm sure they
love this outside doing [ __ ] twirly
worries you don't know how to deal with
[ __ ] actors man that's what is that's
why it is anyway dude
the fighting angels what were they I
don't even know there's [ __ ] that's just
like it's like Oh age-old tradition [ __ ]
tradition [ __ ] is like even with my dad
he would always like want to [ __ ]
read us like polar bear Express or
Midnight Express what the [ __ ] was the
thing the polar bear Express the crib
Christmas every Christmas night and I
was like 25
like that I'm not doing it anymore as I
come on we got a reader we did it since
you were a little I'm like that Ida I'm
[ __ ] 30 you know said come on sit on
my lap come on I'm just like I'm not
doing it my dad I'm 30 did my brothers
26 I'm be taking a come on we got a look
at the pictures like whoa cool yeah
magic is what you think it is magic is
denial but that's emotional was [ __ ] you
sentimental as [ __ ] is what I should say
anyway do it that's it for me you could
text me eight one eight two three nine
seventy eighty seven love that but
trying to [ __ ] text you guys back a
little more because I've been doing the
what do you call it quarantine live show
dates are obviously continuously
changing I'm trying to get out there
when I can I don't I have some dates set
but I'm not announcing them yet so you
know we'll see what happens if I can't
beat him join him though you know that's
the thing I'm sure not to make big
announcements until things are certain
but support the show by buying merch at
store Chris D'Elia calm for just Google
Chris D'Elia merch go watch my special
no pain compete into the world man afire
incorrigible white male black comic you
can watch it and rate and review this
show up online on iTunes or wherever you
can get your stuff anyway guys thank you
remember like friggin reps and you guys
are great have a good day and have a
good weekend see you next time
[Music]
oh wait what was the throw me no throw
me when I'm dead